hey guys it's sep 10 to the 8 my name is
jeff and here's some news related to
gaming the pokemon go accessory called
pokemon go plus which you definitely
would have bought two months ago and
might buy what it actually comes out
Vanel has a release date a little button
on a band allows you to catch pokemon
without having to look at your phone
it'll be out on sep tember 16 in most
countries for 35 bucks unfortunately
pre-orders are currently unavailable in
most retail stores as they've been
bought up pretty quickly pokemon go plus
works by connecting to your phone via
bluetooth smart version 4.0 and
providing alerts about nearby poker
stops and wild pokemon you can cast
pokemon by pressing a button on the
device although you can only catch
pokemon you've already caught before and
the device doesn't alert you to pokemon
attracted by the in-game incense item
the pokemon go plus accessory is
compatible with iphone 5 devices and up
and android devices with version 4.4 to
6.0 installed new Mass Effect Andromeda
details have arrived today indicating
the both the male and female player
characters are present in the game no
matter which you choose to play and
their siblings the Mass Effect series
has always lets you choose your player
characters gender but this time around
both versions will exist in the universe
creative lead on Andromeda Mac Walters
told PlayStation access what people
don't know a little surprise here is
these two a brother and sister they both
exist in the game world at the same time
so if you're playing as the sister the
female rider your brother is somewhere
in the universe he added another fun
little tidbit is the character we saw
two e3's ago in the n7 armor is actually
their father we've got the full rider
family now revealed will do names and
things in the future and you trailers do
to be shown on november seven Bioware's
also recently confirmed that Andromeda
will run at 30 frames per second across
both ps4 and the nucleus were pros
speaking of the ps4 pro sony has
released an FAQ to iron out some of the
details on the new consoles sony
explained that competitive multiplayer
players on ps4 pro will not generally
have a performance advantage over those
playing on the standard ps4 the FAQ
explains play testing and balancing is
to each game developer and while it's
true that ps4 pros more powerful
hardware can drive smoother or more
stable frame rates and supported titles
developers have many tools and processes
they can use to prevent imbalances the
post adds that remote play is expected
to run far better due to the ps4 pros
increased processing power with a
resolution boost to 1080p on Mac PC and
Xperia devices and the pro is expected
to facilitate high quality VR
experiences finally playstation
president andrew house is spoken to the
guardian about why the pro doesn't
include a 4k blu-ray player he explained
our feeling is that while physical media
continues to be a big part of the games
business we see a trend on video towards
streaming certainly with our user base
it's the second biggest use case for
people's time on the system so we place
more emphasis on that area with that
trend towards streaming it appears they
ultimately made the call to drop the 4k
blu-ray player well there won't be any
floor k TV shows or movies in the
playstation store at launch the new
netflix and youtube apps will support 4k
as HDR content although no word yet on
when we can expect them to be out head
together slot for stories uncle to
horizon 3 and destiny and come by again
same time tomorrow for the biggest
stories of the entire week